un ataque intencional así calificó la
policía de San Francisco la agresión
sufrida por el esposo de la presidenta
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos Nancy
pelosigation basados en nuestra
investigación en este momento sabemos
que esto no fue un acto al azar fue
intencional y está mal
pelosi de 82 años Fue embestido a
martillazos en su casa por un intruso
las heridas de la víctima fueron
significativas pero si fue llevado un
hospital local donde fue intervenido por
una fractura de cráneo además de
presentar lesiones en el brazo derecho
la plana mayor demócrata no tardó en
reaccionar
ya es suficiente ya es suficiente toda
persona de buena conciencia debió
ponerse claramente y sin ambigüedades a
la violencia en nuestra política
independientemente de cuáles sean sus
políticas
el presidente reiteró que la frase del
atacante que Preguntaba dónde está Nancy
también se escuchó en los pasillos del
Capitolio durante la toma del 6 de enero
de 2021 la vicepresidenta Harris
calificó el suceso como un hecho por
debajo de la dignidad y la inteligencia
de los Estados Unidos
Esto fue un acto extrema violencia y
creo que estamos viendo un momento en
nuestro país donde hay un discurso muy
alimentado por el odio y la división
[Música]
el estado actual de polpelos y es
prometedor los médicos afirmaron que el
tratamiento a sus heridas fue exitoso y
esperan una recuperación completa del
asalto se dio en un contexto electoral
avivando así los temores de violencia
política Estados Unidos se encuentra a
días de las elecciones de medio término
que decidirá Cuál de los dos grandes
partidos se hace con el control del
congreso